-Good evening, everybody.
I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well.
And now we are going
to get to the news.
Senate Minority Leader
Mitch McConnell yesterday
called President Biden's speech
in Georgia on voting rights,
quote, "profoundly
unpresidential."
Oh, I'm sorry -- is that
something we still track?
What should he have said?
Voting is only for 9s and above?
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
has reportedly found a loophole
that will allow Democrats
to bypass
a Republican filibuster
on a new voting rights bill.
All he had to do to find it
was push his glasses up
to their normal height.
"Oh! There it is!"
Confidants of former
Vice President Mike Pence
reportedly believe
that he is preparing
to run for president in 2024,
though I think he's just in it
for the security detail.
Amid accusations of nepotism,
it was announced yesterday
that New York Mayor Eric Adams
has demoted his brother
from deputy police commissioner
to executive director
of mayoral security.
Still not as bad
as when Mayor Giuliani
gave his cousin the job of wife.
During a speech --
Sometimes you're bummed
that there's not
an audience around.
During a speech yesterday
on the Senate floor,
Republican Senator Marco Rubio
described the life
of a typical liberal
as watching MSNBC,
morning Peloton bike rides,
drinking caramel macchiatos,
and eating avocado toast.
Are you kidding me?
Do you know how many calories
are in a caramel macchiato?
I'm not gonna throw away
my Peloton ride like that.
Supreme Court heard
oral arguments on Tuesday,
and Justice Neil Gorsuch
was reportedly
the only member
not to wear a face mask.
Even worse, they're letting him
play in the Australian Open.
An ex-girlfriend of Republican
congressman Matt Gaetz
reportedly testified yesterday
before a federal grand jury.
After being thanked
for cooperating, she said,
"Hey, anything to get out
of gym class."
Organizers of the annual
Toy Fair New York trade show
canceled the event this week
for the second year in a row
amid a rise
in coronavirus cases,
which is for the best because
they were about to launch
the new Cough on Me Elmo.
Three men were arrested
in New York recently
after they allegedly
impersonated police officers
to rob a suspected drug dealer
of more than $150,000
and 3 kilograms of cocaine.
Even crazier, the suspected
drug dealer who called the cops.
"Yeah, I'd like to report
a robbery of some, uh...
various items."
Actress Megan Fox
and musician Machine Gun Kelly
announced their engagement
yesterday
and said they drank
each other's blood.
That's right --
he got down on one knee,
then two knees,
then passed out from blood loss.
And finally,
according to a new study,
exercising for 20 minutes a day
can reduce the risk
of developing dementia.
Finally, conclusive evidence
that golf is not exercise.
And that was a monologue.